hello everyone and welcome back to the
after show my name is Mark Ellis and one
summer in college I painted houses not
like they do in the irishman that's what
we're talking about today if you've not
yet seen the film the Irishman be warned
the spoilers will follow this movie is
currently 99% fresh on the tomato meter
with critics 98 critics are weighing in
so far that's bound to increase we'll
see how the tomato meter responds so
excited to talk about this movie Martin
Scorsese's latest is it his greatest I
certainly have two great panelists here
today
Angie Hahn is joining us and Scott Matz
the the Irish man the Irish man yes
that's the sequel that's probably gonna
be an even longer film the critics
consensus right now guys on Rotten
Tomatoes reads as an epic gangster drama
that earns its extended runtime the
Irishman finds Martin Scorsese
revisiting familiar themes to poignant
funny and profound effect so before we
get really into this conversation I just
want to get y'all's take is this movie
fresh or rotten Scott do you agree with
what it is on the tomato meter
absolutely I think that it's up there
for a reason you know Martin Scorsese
this is his 26th feature film not his
first mock movie one of his best
is it his greatest we'll find out during
this conversation I wanna spoil at the
top but I think it is absolutely worthy
of all the raves it lives up to the hype
it is definitely not his first crime
movies Angie do you agree with with
Scott is this a fresh movie in your eyes
for me yes and it's also one that like
as I was watching it I started out
liking it and I feel like I liked it
more and more as I was going so you
gotta be honest at first I was just like
I don't know like people were very high
on this movie and I was like okay it's
pretty good and then by the end I was
like yes I'm up there with everyone it's
always one of those things where you go
into a movie and you heard a little bit
of hype from people who got to see
advanced screenings and you're like okay
well first of all do I see this movie in
theaters or do I wait until it's on
Netflix it's got a three and a half hour
runtime I went in I saw this movie and I
think that I continued to fall more in
love with it even after I left the
theater because it is such a long movie
and you feel the length in my opinion
yeah but it doesn't necessarily mean
it's a detriment to the movie like there
isn't a scene I'd lose yeah
do you feel the length but in a good way
because I feel like what works for it
like length the length works for it
because by the end you really want to
feel the weight of everything that has
happened and that wouldn't work if it
had been like a 90-minute movie well
well you know what you said about how
you know you went in initially you were
like oh I don't know but then it got
better as it went along
I mean I rack so absolutely feel that
that's the strength of this movie is
that it does get better as it goes along
and I also think that the running time
is justified because unlike Goodfellas
or Casino which are very very fast paced
quick cut movies this movie is a little
more restrained compared to those films
you don't have those quick cuts the
scenes are allowed to breathe the
performances are allowed to breathe so
you need more time to get into it for
the movie to a sort of cast its spell
over you yeah but it also goes places
especially towards the end in the last
hour where none of Scorsese's mob movies
have gone and the performances in this
movie are are off the hook well that's
why I was happy that I tie my bathroom
break correctly if you haven't seen the
movie it was about two and a half hours
in because like I and I got back and I
sat down and I might have gotten some
more popcorn and then I knew there's a
there's a certain twist that happens
with the film and you're like oh god
okay don't miss that wait De Niro is
gonna have to take care of Pacino's
character himself the Irishman is gonna
have to take care of Jimmy Hoffa himself
and I was so glad that I could just
enjoy that last 45 minutes hour the
movie and all the other surprises that
are in there because it's got I think
you hit on something that this is a
familiar tone with what Martin Scorsese
has done in the past obviously with like
Goodfellas and Casino but the filmmaking
is different and the tote is a little
different too this isn't quite as
violent it's a little bit more of a a
tender take well a tender for a mob film
okay house is being painted but you you
feel sort of empathy for for Robert De
Niro's Frank Sheeran
the Irishman of the title so like look
at a filmmaker like Clint Eastwood he
made a bunch of westerns and then he
waits until just the right time to make
the greatest one of the greatest
questions of all time his best Western
which was Unforgiven
that was his coda that was his career
capper for the westerns it doesn't get
better than that
I feel like that's the sort of tone that
Scorsese is taking with the Irishman
yeah it makes for really interesting
companion with his other gangster movies
because I feel like one of the big
differences is like you know you watch
like Goodfellas and like obviously you
also see like the dark side of it and
like there's a whole downfall and
everything so it's not like everything
is great but it's such such a movie
about like the appeal and the allure and
the grant glamor and the excitement of
like this this world whereas I feel like
this movie doesn't really do that like
it doesn't really look like even as
you're entering this world with him it
doesn't really look that sexy it just
kind of looks like you know it's it's
his job he's working is it almost too
early to try to rank this movie against
his other crime films because you know
that I think that we're such a prisoner
at the moment sometimes where I just saw
the Irishman and oh my god it's such a
different way for some of these
performers like it was a totally
different Pesci you got a casino in
Goodfellas but I I can't it as I'm
thinking about it today I'm thinking the
Irishman might be just as good of a film
as Goodfellas in casino I just don't
know if it's as rewatchable Wow okay
well I think that that the Irishman is
definitely rewatchable to the extent I
can't wait to watch it again and here's
the beauty of it you could see it in
theaters during the three-week run it
has before it does drop on nefler you're
going to see anything when you send
people to the theater I would absolutely
say you got to see this movie on the big
screen forget about the running time
just let yourself get consumed by the
film it is absolutely worthy this is a
milestone a landmark cinematic
achievement and that always does need to
be seen on the big screen but but
there's something about the comfort of
knowing that a movie is three and a half
hours long and watching it at home and
you go okay I'm gonna pause it here I'll
watch the rest of it tomorrow and you
know what you watch it over and over
again and in terms of ranking them I
found it I find it really difficult
because I like them for such different
reasons they're doing such different
things they're such different films I'm
like I don't know to me they work so
well together like I'm like I don't know
why I'd pit them against each other
oh no no not pitting them against each
other
I'm like like I'm like trying to compare
like which one's better and I'm like I
don't know my my to me like the part of
the fun is like that they worked so well
together as like bookends of like this
kind of career that he's had not that
this is his last movie or that
Goodfellas is his first movie but you
know he was much younger when he made
that that one and he's much older now
but then ask your other question about
whether I tell people to go see it I
think yes I don't necessarily know that
it's gonna be something that like you
can just pop on at midnight and suddenly
watch all three hours of right you know
whatever but like but I do think that
part of the reason I would advise anyone
whose interest in this movie to go see
it in theaters is because I think it's
kind of a film that requires some
patience and I don't know about you but
like I find it sometimes very difficult
even when I'm enjoying a movie to watch
a movie that requires a lot of patience
at home because there's just so many
distractions around like I was really
glad that especially because I think the
first hour is a little bit slower I was
really glad that I was watching it in
this situation where I there was like no
escape right it's a compliment to
Dolomites is my name that I didn't pick
up my phone once watching that from home
because that's her it was like it's hard
just in the modern world we live and
it's very tough you have to focus on
anything for 3 minutes much less three
and a half hours so I I would tend to
recommend see in the theater if you have
the means and it's also because I think
that the theater experience is gonna
make the d aging look a little cleaner
I've noticed that with the aging when I
was watching rogue one the other day at
home and it's like they did a different
thing with grand moff tarkin there than
what Scorsese did with the de-aging but
it's still it comes across more as an
effect on the small screen to me anyway
because the de-aging and this did not
take me out of the story at all and I
was thrilled a little bit it did a
little bit in the beginning yeah like
it's for obviously first noticeable when
you see how when you see the younger
versions of Scorsese and as Al Pacino
and Frank Sheeran played by DeNiro and
Joe Pesci's character it it's definitely
you're alerted to it it you're it's
noticeable but it's just there's like a
glassy eyes but again I don't know if
they're just making his eyes glassy for
different reasons cuz that's how the guy
felt like it was a little bit of the
skin - I was I was looking you know I
was looking at the whole package
watching I was like okay so this is the
de-aging process they were talking about
but the narrative of the film did take
over the characters took over and here's
why I think
ultimately the de-aging process was more
crucial to - then rather than casting
younger actors to play the younger
versions of these characters you're with
these images from start to finish three
and a half hours like decades and it
makes you draw into the characters more
you're more vested emotionally to the
characters and the stakes and the
epicness of it all when you're seeing
one person play the same character over
the course of whatever five decades I
think especially when that person is so
recognizable in the role like this where
you have De Niro Pacino Pesci Harvey
Keitel it's a great nugget from
Charlotte of Sullivan she said if this
is something of a tall story though it's
an irresistible one with Pesci and
Harvey Keitel especially sharp so it's
like this is not just a movie for the
headliners for odin ear and Pacino in a
movie together like I thought Pesci
stole the entire movie I think De Niro
could get nominated but Angie I think
Joe Pesci playing against type from what
we saw him in Goodfellas in casino I
think this was a landmark achievement
for him I thought he was incredible in
this like I you know like you it's not
that not that you expect anything less
than greatness from any of these people
but like like you said it's it's so
different from what we've seen him do
before and I feel like that really adds
the experience to where like you kind of
uh I kind of felt myself projecting his
like kind of intensity onto this
character and kind of like even when
he's restrained you feel like there's
something in and waiting to just like
just because I know Joe Pesci movies
waiting for him to turn into leo guest
from lethal everybody but he's just so
quiet and so reserved the whole time and
it makes for such a powerful dynamic you
know Joe Pesci is great in this film and
he is completely different like the way
we seen him in Goodfellas and and Casino
and Lethal Weapon - buddy but I it is
really for me great to see Pesci making
his first movie in nine years you know
he came out of retirement so to speak to
do this film and it was definitely
worthy but I think the standout here
while there - really one of them is De
Niro
you know Robert De Niro especially in
the last hour of this movie is as good
as he has ever been he has to be
nominated and I think he's a
front-runner
to actually win that's a hot sake Angie
you you think denier is the frontrunner
in the Best Lead performance category I
don't know just because it's it's just
so early like I could definitely see him
being a really strong contender but I
agree with you it's a movie we're like
altering these well through these
leading men have been you know really
just thought of as icons for ever and
like you know they've had towering
reputations and whatnot and I do feel
like sometimes when an actor gets to
that level it becomes easy to stop kind
of appreciating what they're doing it
becomes easy to take them for granted it
becomes easy to kind of like you know
just kind of be like oh yeah sure I'm
sure he's great whatever but then this
is this is one of those movies where you
see all through them and you're just
like oh right like this is it's such a
vital reminder of like this is why we
worship them so much on the first place
and this is why they're still so
exciting and why it's still thrilling to
go see them on the big screen one of the
best scenes of the movie it's not what
you think it's not it's not a whacking
scene and which by the way well another
thing that separates this from other mob
movies especially Scorsese movies no one
uses the word whacked no one uses the
word forget about it it doesn't fall
prey to we're just paying out but the
scene okay so if this is a spoil or
heavy show so we see Frank Sheeran knock
off Jimmy Hoffa by Al Pacino we'll get
to Pacino in a second but the the scene
when Frank Sheeran DeNiro has to call
Ginny off his wife and offer his
condolences and say I'm really sorry
don't worry you know I'm here for you if
you need me I'll talk to you tomorrow
like an expert a master craftsman a
master class in acting right there he
knows what he did his daughter knows
what he did okay Anna Paquin and he has
to pretend like he's there for his wife
that moment is just going this guy is a
freakin genius I'm glad you brought up
the the Anna Paquin scene because they
had a pact when I thought gave kind of a
it definitely doesn't have a lot of line
now mm-hmm but such a powerful haunting
performances as the daughter who knows
exactly what her daddy's into and we'd
get that matriculation of when she's a
little girl and seeing him and how
Fuhrman of a defender he is but also you
grow up and you get older and I saw that
there was an interesting article there's
been a few of them this week about
Scorsese and the fact that
women are by and large not involved in
this story while they're silent and they
even at the beginning of the movie it's
almost like they're a nuisance cause we
have to pull over to so that so that
they can smoke so how did you feel about
the lack of a strong female role in this
where do you think Anna Paquin fit that
bill well I think effect one really fits
the like I wouldn't say like oh like
she's like she's this powerful female
character because she is very much a
character whose whole role is being on
sidelines like watching what's going on
she's very few lines she doesn't like
actually do that much or drive that much
of the action or anything like that that
said like I think that I think to me it
made sense that the women were so
secondary in this movie just because it
seems like that's how that's the role
that they fill in the lives of these men
that the movie is actually about it
doesn't seem like Robert De Niro
particularly kind of you know
understands his daughter that well it
seems like his character sees her as
more of a symbol so it makes sense to me
that the movie about him would also see
her that way and yeah I think that Anna
Paquin's performance was actually very
very very strong I mean that's what
acting is you know show us don't tell us
and for the duration of when the
daughter is her age and Anna Paquin is
paying her we see what she's feeling
we're not told and I think that's that's
that's a mix it for a more powerful
performance and I do agree with you I
think if the movie took place today if
it was a mob movie about today I think
it would have been much much different
where yes the women should have had much
much stronger more prominent roles women
existed in the 1950s and they were doing
things so I don't necessarily know that
it's fair to say like well like you know
women weren't really around and doing
anything so movie set in the 1950s
wouldn't have them but I do think that
in this movie like that's not how he saw
his wife that's not great that's not how
the other men saw their wives are the
women in their lives so yeah like okay
sure I'm not saying like oh you know I'm
not trying to be like oh yes it's fine
like let's have no like strong female
characters in any movies or anything but
I'm saying you know you got it you got
to look at it for what works for the
specific movie and then this one I was
like okay it makes sense to me
well listen let's talk about Pacino in
this movie yeah because you know what
first of all Al Pacino in a movie
directed by Martin Scorsese are you
kidding tip this has never happened this
is Al Pacino's
first movie with Martin Scorsese after
working with all these amazing directors
I mean and only now a 2019 are we
finally seeing this happen first of all
perfect fit perfect so that scene when
he's a when Robert is that he's a dinner
and he's trying to have to explain to
Jimmy Hoffa what's gonna happen and
Jimmy Hoffa is just not getting it okay
I wanted to just like crawl under a
blanket and diets yeah so tense in so
heartbreaking yeah you think about all
the scenes in this movie and what it
adds up to is again I mean you're seeing
a lot of critics mention the runtime but
not necessarily that it's a detriment
naturally lens talk of could it be a
Best Picture nominee could a win Best
Picture and what does this mean for
Netflix coming off of the wind with Romo
last year okay making them a bigger
player in the game okay the Roman went
for last year was for foreign film
director and cinematography now last
year Netflix really got behind Romo
obviously because we all got those roma
pillows but this year this year
especially 2019 is really the year that
Netflix came to the party and took over
and and and took the stage you know not
only do they have the Irishman they have
Dolomites as my name they have marridge
story they have the two popes like they
are doing real actual quality driven
cinematic features that are playing in
theaters before they eventually drop on
Netflix but the other thing with the
Irishman is is it is it a frontrunner to
win
possibly because when Martin Scorsese
won Best Picture and director for the
departed I like The Departed but back in
2006 that movie opened October 6 2006
good man when the departed came out I
remember when I saw it I thought really
good film but not when a Scorsese's best
and I don't think it's really an Oscar
contender boy was I wrong but was it his
Best Picture
I mean was it better at the taxi driver
was a better than Goodfellas was it
better than Raging Bull no no no that
movie won director in picture because it
was saying no to Lifetime Achievement
Award right we gotta give it to them
sometimes right here's an opportunity
right but guess what
now he's making a movie or another is
that is as good as those films and
you're going like this is the movie
that's Chrissy she act Ecco says he
actually
should have won the Academy Award for
director and best picture for and maybe
he will because I think people will be
like this is an amazing film
alright so quickly let's talk about the
movies that they the Irishmen might be
going up against it or not Netflix films
what are some of your other Best Picture
contenders parasite parasites a big one
ha ha my farewell I feel like I've heard
people guessing dodo rabbit as well
Jojo rabbit I mean that dip when the top
prize in Toronto and and that is a good
mother I think that Jojo rabbit will
definitely get nominate it did that up
won best pictures there you go yeah so I
think Georgia rabbit is is one of those
I put that with a farewell to where it's
like because we have we have 10 nominees
and the farewell came out a little bit
ago but I think that you could
definitely have a campaign that gets
that back into the the forefront of
voters mind so I think that's definitely
a contender and then films that have yet
to be released we just don't know what
the summer's gonna bring it with the
quality those movies are gonna be and I
haven't seen Ford vs. Ferrari yet but
that's where our Ford Ferraris fantastic
I've seen it twice and that is absolute
eyes I've seen it twice actually it is
absolutely know where I stand where you
say yeah but no no I mean mark the the
other film that we're not talking about
that it's absolutely a Best Picture
contender and I to me like where I sit
right now on this date taping this my
favorite movie of the year is marriage
story and that is also a Netflix film
yeah and that's like the Kramer vs
Kramer of the 21st century it's a
brilliant masterful film written and
directed by Noah Baumbach you also have
night it's 1917 directed by Sam Mendes
that's not opening until December
they're not screening it until the
weekend of November 23rd and 24th and
the people are gonna really see it that
that's how this one-take experiment
worked
I don't well cats could go either way
I'm hoping it goes the good way but that
trailer was like really awkward so the
towers first fans loved it I I think it
that it's good that we don't know
exactly for sure yeah this is the moon
yeah some people are speculating I don't
necessarily agree with this but that it
could be a Tarantino versus Scorsese
because you know once upon a time in
Hollywood certainly deserves
consideration absolutely yeah that's
another thing it's just it's just so
early like I don't think that
necessarily this time last year people
would have been like green
look obviously the winner so a lot of
things can happen like I think we can
make our guesses about like which ones
we think are worthy and which ones we
think are likely given what we know
about what has done well in the past but
we don't know for sure I will say that
Netflix I feel like they've been trying
to get like you know establish
themselves as like a major award season
player for a while I mean it started
years ago with like piece of donation
which went nowhere and it seems like
they're getting closer and closer and
irishman is this seems like a really
good shot like you've got a director
that everyone loves and kind of gracious
has unanimously agreed is a you know
master filmmaker you've got him like you
know playing a different variation on a
theme that we have always liked from him
in the past you've got these three
actors that you know again are very well
respected it happened for a long time so
the other thing you touched on this
about about the freedom yeah freedom of
working with Netflix the irishman was
originally set up at Paramount and when
the budget started to creep up past a
hundred million paramount you know short
story just said yeah thanks no thanks of
what we're gonna let this go you feel
free to take it elsewhere well you know
when the producer is like Jane Rosenthal
is long time producing partner of Robert
De Niro they shopped it around and
nobody was actually biting at their
heels to take on Irishman because the
budget kept creeping up they did not
think that it was a sure thing or a
slam-dunk despite the fact that you have
Pesci and De Niro and and an Al Pacino
and an Harvey Keitel and all these like
long time players despite the fact that
this is going to be the ninth film that
the Scorsese and De Niro made together
it's a mob movie which everyone loves a
mob movie
so then Netflix says actually hey we'll
take it here's a blank check go make
your movie you have complete creative
control the movie costs one hundred and
fifty million dollars to make okay and
you're probably gonna get a whole lot of
people subscribing to Netflix just to
watch Irishmen if they don't see it in
theaters that's right this business
model is different so what they what
they kind of the calculations that
they're making when they try to decide
like how much money am I going to give
to this filmmaker is not gonna be
exactly the same calculations that you
know Warner Brothers or Disney or Sony
or something else is making I think
Michael Phillips said it really well
from the Chicago Tribune he said this
movie it moves forward and backward and
sideways getting more unpredictable
and compelling as it goes it's a worthy
theater experience in my mind it's
actually playing in a limited run in
theaters right now it's also gonna be
streaming for Thanksgiving so here's the
big question here's the last question of
the day when do you put on the Irishman
during the Thanksgiving weekend is it is
it what you're watching instead of
football during the day do you have the
meal and then put it on Thanksgiving
night there's a risk of falling asleep I
feel like after Thanksgiving meal is
actually terrible time to watch it
because the beginning is the slowest
part oh yeah everyone's like already
like full like you kinda are like oh
you're barely awake as it is you put on
the eye or something really it's a three
and a half hour movie it starts out very
slow and then it becomes like an you
know like a poetic meditation on like
mortality and aging and people are gonna
be like I disagree I think right after
Thanksgiving dinner is the best time to
watch Irishmen because you know what you
are gonna be full yeah it might be a
little tired or whatever but you're
really not going to want to talk to
anybody after sitting at the dinner
table for a few hours doing Thanksgiving
dinner you're gonna just wanted this
chill out and vet you out and watch
something that would be a great family
way like you imagined but no Irishman
it's going to be perfect because I'd be
like oh yeah Scorsese mob movie this is
perfect and I don't have to talk to
anybody else for three and a half hours
the best time to watch it the next
morning
everyone's shopping you're like you're
Co meteors fridge for leftovers are all
still with your family so you guys need
something to do together but now
everyone's like awake you've had your
coffee you're you know or you're gonna
watch it hang you hit pause after two
hours and finish watching the rest of it
the next day well what I was gonna do is
just wait until Cyber Monday that way I
can have a Netflix window open then I
can just do all my Martin Scorsese
intended it to be seen that's what I'm
gonna go to my movie theater right now
thank you so much Scott next angie han
thanks for joining me on this
conversation with the Irishman thank you
all for watching the after show you can
feel free to weigh and at any time
comment right
and let us know your thoughts on the
irishman everything we talked about does
it deserve
Oscar consideration is it the best
Scorsese movie of all time if not what
is your favorite let us know all that
and more in the comments right now
subscribe to this channel here at Rotten
Tomatoes and make sure you click that
belt it's gonna give you an alert every
time we have a new after show for you
until next time my name is Mark Ellis
and be careful you're painting houses
too dirty business